Another heavy-duty topic which is good to know about
is edge caching. To describe this, let's look at
the information flow for your App Engine application. First
of all, users that want to use your application are
connected to their internet service provider. This provider connects
to Google data center. After the DNS lookup has
determined that your application is hosted by Google, Google
then identifies the data center where your App Engine application
run, and starts talking to the App Engine front
end. If the content is dynamic, the App Engine front
end determines the instance that should manage the request.
So these are your App Engine instances that run your
application code. But if the request is for static
content, for example images or static HTML, the front end
can retrieve it directly from the static servers. And in
both cases, the response is returned back to the user.
So this is a good architecture. But as it looks
right now, all the requests have to be sent to
the data center, which hosts your App Engine application. It
would be much better if more content could be served
directly by this data center. First of all, it would
ease the load on this data center, but more importantly,
since it's closer to the users, the response would be
delivered faster. This is exactly what edge caching is all about.
Edge caching is a cache that sits in the
data center closest to the user. So whenever there is
a request, the result can be served directly from
the cache if it's available there, rather than going through
data center 2. That means less load on data
center 2 in your application, and faster responses to your
users. A win-win. So the question is, then, what
do you need to think about to use edge caching?
Well, there are two ways. The first one is
to set the cache-control header, in the HTTP response. This
should only be done if a subsequent request of this
kind would return the same result. The second option is
to define as much content as possible as static.
Since static content does not change, it's great for edge
caching. You can define which content is static through configuration
files. A good opportunity for you to look at the
online documentation. And remember, as most of the time
with caching, there are no guarantees that the content will
be cached, but when it is, it will be
good for both your application as well as your users.